and joining us now with more his first
television interview since taking the
gavel the 55th Speaker of the House of
Representatives Kevin McCarthy
thank you
how was your week last week
it was entertaining you know
I think I built a little Name ID I'm not
quite sure actually I think that's a
good way to put it you know it what's
amazing about this to me and I may be
wrong but tell me if I'm right
because I talked to a lot of members I
know a lot of people in this room
tonight and a lot of you thank you by
the way for coming and some of you are
not going to be on TV but you came
because you wanted to support the
speaker but I have a feeling that 222
people agree on Jim Jordan's
investigation uh and that would be into
whether the FBI is politicized the doj
weaponize they weaponized from
FBI
we've watched him get out of control
with no check and balance but last week
was tough but remember what my father
always said it's not how you start it's
how you finish let me tell you what
happened after last week our very first
bill
we repealed 87 000 irshas we promised to
do that we promised to do it we made it
in our
commitment to America which you've
talked a lot about and we'll check it
off as they go I have my own copy yeah
but you know what you know what else we
did next we just passed
the church style committee that Jim
Jordan will run looking at the
weaponization of government you know
what we just passed right now a select
committee on China and we got 146
Democrats to vote with us Pelosi would
never allow this they had an agreement
with her and she backed away the night
before so you want to bring jobs back
from China to America you want to stop
them from buying our Farmland you want
to stop them from sin is from stealing
our intellectual property this is where
it all starts and this is only our first
couple days in power so the power of the
purse which we'll talk about at like the
power of subpoena those are the two big
Powers you have okay let's go let's
focus on the investigation part Jim
Jordan in Appropriations then we got
James calmer they'll both be joining us
tonight yes and he'll be looking into
the Biden family Syndicate we know
everybody in this room knows one thing a
Joe Biden lied when Joe Biden said not
one time did he ever talk to his son
Hunter about his farm business dealings
we have photographic evidence and
evidence of meetings that had taken
place and witnesses that will attest to
such
documents that they denied us until
we're in the majority do you think the
president and more than 40 years of
being elected why do you think he
finally went to the Border because we
were sworn in he knows what's coming
you've got to secure your border and
we're going to use every Power we have
to make sure we protect this country and
look out for the American taxpayer I
think last week at least a part of it
was Republicans around the country were
disappointed in past speakers I'll give
one example John Boehner I was
disappointed in John Boehner and I think
that there were people that wanted the
assurances I had interviewed you enough
I had asked you repeatedly the
commitments to America I have my version
right here which we'll talk about
and they wanted to know these
investigations were real what other
investigations
government accountable for the whole
the Democrats have been in power
what they've done is increased spending
why don't we have a checking balance
think of this when the Republicans were
in power last time for eight years you
know how much discretionary spending
increased in those eight years zero they
were in power for four years they
increased it by 30 percent they went
from spending 4 trillion to 7 trillion
we don't have that type of money they
created inflation so we've got to get
our we've got to get our country under
control financially how do we do that
too energy policy watch what they've
done to make us weak they made our price
of gas go up but they made us weak
around the world we're gonna become
energy independent
our borders not secure but look what
they have done to our schools as well
right we're going to pass a parent's
Bill of Rights also when you think about
this as well when we look at checks and
balances you got Comer oversight you got
Jim Jordan a Judiciary but every single
committee has an oversight committee so
every dollar matters how we spend it and
we're going to be looking at everything
no more blank checks okay and by the way
you will vote on every Appropriations
Bill independently yes all 12 of them
yes okay we'll get to that I want what
other investigations okay first of all
covet why don't we know where covet
started they wouldn't have any hearings
on it we'll have that why shouldn't we
know what happened in Afghanistan those
last two months 13 gold star families
have a right to know but more
importantly this nation has a right to
know so it never happens again we should
know what happened with China and where
the money's going we know the documents
are there I think the country has a
right to know that as well but the
weapon organization of what the FBA
Anthony fauci well that goes right into
covet we have our own ability to oversee
that and look into that I have a lot of
questions whether or not he was honest
what did he know did our tax dollars
through the NIH was it funneled through
the what was the the echo Alliance
whatever the group was called were we
giving money to the Wuhan lab a virology
with a new gain of function research
took place where they knew coronavirus
research took place uh okay so we have
that investigation of the Afghanistan
investigation the FBI the doj uh the
Biden family investigation
now let's get to the issue of finances
and money and spending and why don't you
explain how this process now will be
different and we're coming up against
the debt ceiling vote and what that's
going to mean that might be the first
test of how committed the Republican
Party in the houses to really holding
the line on spending am I wrong on that
no you're not wrong on that but think
for one moment we cannot one of the
greatest threats we have to this nation
is our debt it makes us weak in every
place that we can we have never been at
this high of debt to GDP except during
World War II and what are we funding
wasteful Washington spending much of the
time so we think if you had a child and
you gave them a credit card and they
kept hitting the limit do you just
increase the limit or do you change
their behavior This is Our Moment to
change the behavior to make sure that
hard-working taxpayer that we're not
wasting their money you're going to tell
me there's not waste out there so we're
going to look at every single dollar
spent we're going to audit it we're
going to make sure we change our
behavior that we can balance our budget
and make us stronger many years ago
Connie Mack from Florida the Penny Plan
I think probably we need the 25 cent
plan at this point because the debt has
gone up so significantly
is that something you think about we
think about a lot this is this is part
of our discussion last week and it was
healthy at the end of the day you might
not like to be but we're stronger today
to have gone I just wish you would have
done it before January 3rd yeah we try
to talk to a lot of your friends some in
this room but I won't give them up look
but I think about at the end of the day
everybody found that we had an agreement
that's kind of what our rules package
does we go to germannus we also wanted
to protect ourselves from the Senate
they won't do their work they won't pass
any appropriation bills and then they
try to jam us what right before
Christmas with 1.7 trillions of dollars
you know what I went over to the Senate
to their lunch and I said we'll never
take up an omni again you have to pass
your appropes bills individually we'll
pass ours just the way Congress is
supposed to by the way what they did in
the Senate I believe as a conservative
that was a disgrace yeah I think and
they knew you were coming into power and
they knew they couldn't why wouldn't
they just wait if they waited that we'd
have a stronger hand exactly we wouldn't
be increasing it and they in increase
the Baseline where it just adds so much
more to our children let's talk about a
moment maybe it comes sooner maybe it
comes later on the debt ceiling and you
know how the argument will unfold it'll
be Republicans are shutting down
government I've been around this game
too long government never shuts down
essential services will exist Grandma
Mom and Dad they're going to get their
social security check Medicare is not
going to be shut down the military is
not going to be shut down now there
might be people that get furloughed but
odds are pretty high that when they get
their free vacation they will get back
pay
but that will be the argument now the
question will be it'll become a game of
chicken
and that is Republicans are shutting
down the government and they're not
willing to raise the debt ceiling and
you're going to say what well listen it
doesn't have to come to that I've
already spoken to the president let's
sit down now let's find a way that we
can both come together to actually curve
the rising debt that we have and talk to
Joe Biden he called me the other day and
this is the first conversation I had
with him right when he went down before
you know who you are he did at that
moment ouch come on that's funny I don't
know they want to talk before by the way
you're not responsible for what I say go
ahead but look we'll work with anybody
but we're also one branch in here we
control Congress and you know what we
have funding powers and we want to
utilize it to represent the American
public we don't want to put us in any
Jeopardy whatsoever but we won't don't
want to just have this runaway spending
what they've had increasing 30 percent
in in four years how much no American
house before this debt ceiling
we had probably the summer time okay
we've got plenty of time we're working
on it now but we're setting the plan to
actually put us on to a path to balance
that's what our discussions were all
about what's the what's the relationship
now like with the leadership in the
Senate because you were begging them not
to do this Omnibus to go forward with a
CR instead A continuing resolution they
didn't do that they had the best
opportunity
um so how's the world I want to I want
to empower the Republicans in the Senate
utilize us
Schumer runs the Senate but it's a close
majority but why don't they work with us
so I'm setting up every committee chair
here to work with the ranking Republican
over there let's talk with our bills
together let's take their amendments put
them into ours and move them over there
to empower them to be stronger if I said
right now I've told Schumer do not send
an Omnibus over here if you don't pass
appropriation bills we're not taking it
up so we'll pass our appropriation bills
and then send a continuing resolution
we're not shutting down the government
we're doing our work and we're setting
it up where the American public is
protected but we're also putting a
little cut on there let you talk like
the Penny Plan you're using the power
that was given to you by the American
people exactly and by the way that's
fiscal responsibility and one of your
commitments in the election
look I know Republicans may not have
done well but in the last two elections
the Republicans in the house did very
well maybe the governors didn't maybe
the senator but we won every single time
that's why you're in the majority they
fired the Democrats and they fired Nancy
Pelosi we were going to stand up for
exactly what the commitment said an
economy that's strong a Nations that's
safe
future that's built on freedom and a
government that's held accountable let
me ask you this question what did you
make of this story about Joe Biden and
top secret classified information
especially after what he said about
President Trump especially after the
raid at Mar-A-Lago especially after
Hillary Clinton remember the the July
2016 press conference uh Jim Comey no
reasonable prosecutor would ever
prosecute way more top secret classified
information never mind the deleted
emails with bleach bit and the destroyed
devices with hammers and the removal of
SIM cards what does that mean now in
terms of all those Democrats that wanted
Donald Trump arrested almost immediately
you don't have to eat their words but
the hypocrisy think about this they've
gotten away with so much for so long
this was discovered before the last
election just like the laptop they think
they can allow the American public they
think they can control the media control
companies to shut down if one media
company writes about it they think
they're Above the Law why weren't they
rated why didn't they have the FBI
coming in why didn't he in 60 minutes
say well I understand that because I bet
I have the same problem did Barack Obama
have some of this when he was writing
his book
does Hillary Clinton have some and you
know what all those people have been in
government for years
president Trump just ran for president
do you think he knew everything you
think he went and moved his own boxes
and you know what they were locked away
bidens were not and how many years after
did he have them the FBI actually went
to Mar-A-Lago they looked at all those
documents they asked for a padlock the
padlock request was granted and then all
of a sudden a raid they think the law
doesn't apply to them they think they
write their own and that's what
infuriates the American public America
Believes In fairness and honesty and
that's not what we're getting from them
and we are just getting things started
and on that note we continue with
speaker McCarthy he'll stay with us
we'll check in with congresswoman Elise
stefanik House Majority Leader Steve
scalise and well the big investigations
will be James Culver and Jim Jordan they
will join us and much more as we
continue we're in Washington D.C we're
in the swamp we're only here for 24
hours or less and we'll be back in just
a short time stay with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else